ciro perelli bonjour merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france
alors première question peut-on
s'attendre à une forte abstention pour
ce référendum
écoutez paul et paul à l'abstention je
vous dis la vérité ne constituera pas un
problème et je vous explique pourquoi
les c'est moi et permettez moi de vous
donner quand même un coup législatives à
cette interview par rapport au
référendum alors vous devez savoir à
quai le référendum est l'expression
maximum de la volonté populaire
en fait il s'agit des lances qui du
juridique de la démocratie directe
vous savez que la démocratie les comment
dire l'étymologie de la parole et des
mousses plus créatives donc ça veut dire
la volonté du peuple le peuple
aujourd'hui en italie est appelée aux
urnes pour exprimer sa volonté est là sa
volonté
la volonté du peuple aujourd'hui est
manifestée pour approuver ou les rejeter
la loi de révision constitutionnelle et
je vous répondre à votre question
l'abstention n'essaiera pas entre blaye
pourquoi pas ce qu'est aujourd'hui nous
sommes appelés aux urnes pour un
référendum confirmatif vous savez qu'il
ya en italie comme en france
deux types des référendums il y a le
référendum confirmatif il ya le
référendum abrogatif alors le référendum
qu'on fait confirmatif savait dire le
peuple il doit juste approuvé ou rejeté
les lois des révisions
constitutionnelles
l'abstention n'est pas un problème alors
c'est moi pourquoi ce vote il fait tant
polémique avant même avant même d'avoir
eu lieu le rappelle que le nombre de
députés pourraient passer de 630 à 400
et celui des sénateurs 2 315 à 200 da
écouter
vous avez gay il y a déjà une année et
nous avions eu en italie la double
approbation assembler le modifier la loi
constitutionnelle
j'avoue je vais vous l'appliquez
aujourd'hui nous devons modifier les
articles 56 57 et 59 de notre
constitution afin de pouvoir modifier
les articles constitutionnels en italie
comme en france d'ailleurs
nous avons besoin d'une double
approbation a semblé une douche la
chloration assemblée à laquelle il y à
une année nous avons obtenu une première
délibération
savait-il que la loi elle est passée à
la chambre des députés a prouvé qu'elle
est passé à la chambre du sénat a
approuvé mais qu'est ce qu'il s'est
passé
une deuxième délibération en deuxième
délibération l'assemblée n'a pas obtenu
la majorité absolue tu donc ça veut dire
les deux tiers de la majorité
parlementaire
à ces moments là on a on a eu la
possibilité de pouvoir appliquer
l'article 138 aligné 2 de la
constitution qui prévoit qu'un certain
nombre des sénateurs peuvent demander le
référendum pourquoi elle s'est passé
tout ça si tout à fait une histoire
politique
je vais vous rappeler que l'un des
dernières pendant le mois d'août 2010 9
il y avait un gouvernement movimento
twister ligue qui avait déjà prouvé aux
premières délibérations assembler la loi
d'élections constitutionnel alors
justement si ainsi le oui si le oui
l'emportait ce que ça va impliquer pour
le mouvement 5 étoiles ah bah écoutez si
le oui il est remonté comme sais quoi
parce que je vous répète l'abstention
négoce titubant problème il s'agit d'un
réseau les dom concile mathis et pablo
crédible donc savez dink et l'intention
n'est pas expression d'une non dé la
volonté bobolais disons que le mouvement
le mouvement tchimou est-il il vend à
consolider sa position politique par
rapport à la contre la caste et les
privilèges en fait le moment touchwiz
tel il a voulu un
ces couples font des bas la société la
lutte contre la casse et aujourd'hui il
appelait les cales en 6 millions six
cent quarante à 1856 citoyenne italienne
a modifié la loi constitutionnelle à la
pomme a une approbation au mondial dès
la loi des révisions et dernière
question rapidement si le oui
permettrait 57 millions d'euros
d'économies pour l'état par an pas
suffisant pour la plupart des experts
réduire les frais le salaire des
parlementaires qui est en moyenne de 20
mille euros par mois elle ne s'attelle
pas plus efficace bah écoutez le
l'économie il la présente le 0,1 ou sans
dupil nationale c'est à dire c'est une
bonne démarche pour pouvoir ali vayleux
comme on dit une économie du solide mais
ne constitue qu'un un good à lucien
l'italie et la besoin des réformes sur
le plan du droit social et la besoins
des réformes sur le plan des
infrastructures
disons que le coût des réductions par
rapport aux comme on dit au salève
débat-là m'interpelle a plaisanté le
début le début d'une lutte qui n'est pas
seulement contre la casse mais d'une
lutte qui est l'objet dé ou à donner à
l'économie italienne une comme en guerre
les brise comme on le souhaite pas merci
beaucoup aux tirs opérés dit d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes avocat au barreau bilan